it is of course the season of giving and
starting this morning eight news now is
teamed up with project 150 and Smith's
we're to get food to those who really
need it yeah this morning John langler
and Candace Charles are live at The
Smiths and Sky Canyon with the details
good morning you guys this is a very
popular Smiths I've been in there a few
times they watch us a lot so we're going
to have to you're you guys are gonna
have to come through for us on the food
drive well we're doing the best we're
doing the best we can Sherry the store
hasn't opened yet so even if people
wanted to come in they can't quite just
yet so we got a bit of a head start
Candace is a bit of a head start already
we're not shopping you guys this is
something simple that you guys can get
at the store and put it on in the Box
see look look how simple that is to do
you guys there's lots of options here as
well just you know maybe not bringing
something from your house while you're
while you're shopping at a distance
anywhere in the valley yeah you can help
out the great food drive with eight news
now Smith and of course project 150. yes
yes and we love project 150 we've worked
with them before they do great work and
we're joined by project 150 Kelly
Crystal thank you so much for joining us
this morning tell us a little bit about
the need that you're seeing out there
specifically with teams right right so
right now you know with inflation and
everything going up it's really hard for
these families to put food in their
pantries we deliver to 75 local high
schools every week so we make sure that
they have food in the household whether
they're in the classroom or away from
the classroom so this food helps us
replenish our food pantry to deliver
every week and then again on winter
break when the kids are out of school
and you've talked to some of these kids
what are some of the things that they're
going through so it's really tough right
now
um food insecurity in the household is
challenging parents out of work the cost
of food choosing between paying a power
bill the rent and buying food you know
it's really rough for these families
right now so something as simple as
while you're shopping and grabbing
something could really go a long way
right of course I mean while you're
going down these aisles grab some peanut
butter some rice pasta anything any
non-perishable food drop it in the bin
at checkout we come collect it and then
we distribute it to the high school
students all right Kelly we appreciate
all the work that you're doing the great
food drive is underway John has the box
of course because he's good at holding
boxes and this goes of course all the
way to December 2nd we'll be here all
morning so come on down and check us out
as well the uh the greatest compliment
I've ever heard John is great at holding
boxes I know right oh yeah come to
Smith's we'll be here all morning long
and we'll throw back to you guys in the
studio we want to get these boxes filled
up not just here in Sky Canyon but all
across the valley yeah we want to give
you a workout John if you're going to
hold a box that needs to be full it sure
does stuff the box there you go
there you go let's put some cans in
there thanks guys